hey guys I'm Ryan right Terry I'm Jess
we're already going yeah man hey I don't
know I don't prep people so Justin gamer
friend a mile so creator of the app
slinger it's bomb app III trailers
dropped said he was hanging out I was
like do let's just watch some trailers
together today we're checking out the
trailer Metal Gear Solid 5 phantom pain
the e3 2015 trailer people have a way
for this game forever this is part 2 of
5 I just spray forward I basically play
Metal Gear Solid one two and three
[__] love them I never got around a
four because I couldn't afford a ps4 at
the time and I went broke for like a
solid three years and you know I'm gonna
be buying a ps4 next month so I'm gonna
be catching up on Metal Gear people want
me to check out this trailer I hope it
doesn't ruin too much of the journey for
me
the DAAD you know let's see what happens
and he's even played the like old school
the original yeah crusty
there's no nation we inhabit but a
language make no mistake our native
tongue is our true friend I was born in
a small village I was still a child when
we were raided by soldiers foreign
soldiers he's torn from my elders I was
made to speak their language with each
new post my Master's changed along with
the words they made me speak with each
change I changed to my thoughts
personality how I saw right and wrong
words can chill time and again the
country was ruled by a foreign tongue
when he was a young boy he lost his
native language the bedrock for any
developing child his country his family
his face his identity everything was
stolen from
since ancient times every civilizations
ruler has had the same idea
mumbles unite and the one will they
become stronger than the sum of their
parts and what do rulers use to bring
people together language
this world will become one I have found
the way race tribal affiliations
national borders even our faces will be
irrelevant the world that the boss
envisioned will finally become a reality
and it will make mankind whole again
America is a country of liberty a
meeting of immigrants instead of simply
assimilating its citizens live alongside
others so the major soccer system that
used information words to control the
subconscious in his eyes the greatest
symbiotic parasite the world's ever
known is in microbial its linguistic
words are what keeps civilization our
world alive free the world not by taking
men's lives but by taking their tongues
in their Sun with this i'll rid the
world of infestation psalms lingua
franca the world will be torn asunder
and then it shall be free
the Shin retaliation is what will truly
buy this world together as one
please don't falter read zero kaulder
I heard this is Hideo Kojima's a last
Metal Gear game hmm which is kind of a
bummer but you know maybe it'll be a
really awesome game then hopefully he
goes out guns blazing yeah I love the
mood and tone of this trailer first off
these Metal Gear games tend to just feel
more haunting and yeah more like
emotionally devastated because I think
that's what was the surprise of the
first Metal Gear Solid was I know the
met there was the Metal Gear games but I
remember Metal Gear Solid was a really
launched it it's like starts off like oh
this is a regular mission you gotta save
the president the DARPA chief whatever
yeah and then it just starts taking all
kinds of strange [__] drug it's weird
and I hope this game has a lot of
they're like sort of in and out of game
things that you have to do oh yeah all
I'd kind of introduced the idea of like
breaking the fourth wall and video games
or whatever like you know like having a
way to make the player do unusual things
like you know I don't know stand up or
run around circles of their house or go
knock on walls to get people to get
actually yeah stuff like that like maybe
you know hopefully we'll get something a
little bit of extra in it too but even
if not the realism of it mmm I mean they
obviously used every ounce of the sort
of Konami dollar to productionvalue a
shot at the end you could see the pores
in the woman's face oh yeah they've
always had groundbreaking graphics like
that like they did Metal Gear salt which
was like groundbreaking in gameplay and
then it felt like a movie you know we
hadn't seen a game like that that really
felt like a film
yeah they redid it for gamecube head it
was like why would they even made it
better you know I wonder if any that was
in game footage though we always talked
about when we do you know I come over we
do reactions to games we talked about
you know there's a big difference
between the an entire trailer that's
just cinematics that are rendered
pre-rendered or in actual in-game
footage that's rendered on the fly you
know like that's I have a question you
were saying that it was girls at the end
of the video but what for those look
like one of them might have been liquid
snake to me oh I just meant the one whom
I in the shot at the end of the
helicopter yeah then was it was started
on woman's face and then and then yeah
and then I mean it was
next to her actually stop paying
attention for a second because I was
overwhelmed by the production value in
starting to think about you know yeah I
added a smile akin to put pores on the
person I mean you know and then that led
into that second thought which is I
wonder if it actually looks good they
get that good in gamer obviously not so
what is the end game gonna look like
that's the whole thing I will say like
from the brief time I was able to play
know your four O's I remember thinking
like the game playing the cinematics
look rather similar which would kind of
throw me off because yeah because it is
you know like the cinematics and the
gameplay we usually were very
differentiated yeah I'm when I came up
for ps4 they started looking really
similar which was an interesting thing
to do but I think it works yeah it makes
him interesting certainly doesn't allow
you to like relax you know if you don't
know well you know the way to relax is
masturbate just inseparably and everyone
knows as you play at the end it could
have been solidus snake or it could have
been right and actually because writing
is you know he didn't really have the
best memory of his past they all kind of
look alike that's the point yeah I'm
sure it's intentionally a bit long
characters eyepatch you know stuff like
that
what was he talking about the language
like did you catch were you able to sort
of decipher from it what he meant by the
the language like the without the lingua
franca like Izzy they essentially gonna
go make it so that people can't talk is
that what you think that we're getting
it like that the plot is up that the
evil plot is to make the world lose its
language so then you can't communicate I
think it was saying that if you rip out
someone's tongue and they blow you it
might feel differently oh man never know
I never been blown by someone who
doesn't have a tongue yeah it's gonna be
way better than an Altoid thing yeah
maybe I'll cut off Veronica's tongue see
how that feels and I think we got David
haters voice at one point like thirty
second when did the whole thing about
change I forgot the line I was like
thinking it's not like David Hare
somebody else jumped in there thank you
guys for saying that was out if you're
new to the channel you can subscribe to
the real rejects oh you could also
download Justin's slinger app Justin
ten-second s4e Shane you got ten seconds
now download the app you get to try all
the newest and best stuff from the album
companies if you like it you get to send
it their friends your friends and
negative try it for you too
do eat you got time for a dick joke and
you can boss on Facebook Instagram
Twitter and vine where if we get enough
followers we can get product placement
people
that's right meaning lot of money for me
no benefit for you haha
that's not true the more money you're
gonna go on flowing through around here
the better this video is gonna get
another family you know that's what
people say I'm like I'm not gonna invest
it into these videos we're just gonna
spend it all I'm just gonna blow yeah Oh
crease shooting blow heroin yeah ecstasy
adderall to wake up and concentrate the
next day and a sauna sweat it out your
system that's that famous quote by
George Willis he said he said I spent
90% of my money on women and drink and
the rest I wasted that's that's awesome
I'm glad you look after the tourists is
too sophisticated